I wanna do a stans for stains with you.
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
What is your most frequent stain dilemma?
My pants usually, because I just, when I'm eating
I'm a little messy,
and blood often, sometimes, yeah.
All right, that's good 'cause we have blood out here.
Oh good, good, good.
Today, I'm gonna try something for the first time.
Okay.
When you said blood, I thought hydrogen peroxide.
So I'm gonna actually learn on the stans for stains
with you.
Let's learn.
Take a paper towel.
Now here's number one.
I want you to take it and I want you to dab
like a little bunny, like, I want you do that.
Okay. (laughs)
And you wanna dab the paper towel,
because this is gonna, it's lift, lift!
We're lifting.
Don't push.
Oh oh, sorry.
No, not you, I'm just saying in general.
Not yelling at you, I'm yelling at life.
And anyone, don't hesitate, don't think that stain's
gonna get like, "Oh it's there, it'll be fine in an hour."
You get on that thing right now.
It's like a woman that you don't wanna lose
from like, marrying, you go after it!
Yes.
You're a bear, you get that salmon!
(Johnny growls)
And so, that is already going to take off a top layer
that you will not have to contend with later.
(applause)
And, you know, you just,
this is important in the process of stain removing.
It's a layering technique.
Sure, sure.
Just don't question it and follow.
Not you, life.
All right, now we're gonna take a cotton pad
and we're gonna blot it with the hydrogen peroxide.
All right.
See, we have little
beakers here?
Oh, is this
hydrogen peroxide?
Yeah.
And you're gonna douse.
All right.
And we're taking off the third layer,
or are we doing something else?
This is the second, yeah.
And you just go.
In fact, I don't, this is,
Oh, yes!
Just go after it, forget the sponge!
Yes!
(applause)
All right.
Do you see that?
Oh my God, this, I literally dreamt this up.
I was like, "I just know hydrogen peroxide's
gonna get in there."
Okay, now this is when you wanna break out your tool.
(Johnny laughs)
I don't think we can on this television show.
Whip it out, Johnny.
Whip it out.
Come on.
Get that brush out.
Do you see how the bristles work the magic?
And what's important is you don't wanna put a colored soap.
A colored soap has dye in it.
Especially when you're working on a white t-shirt
type of surface.
And don't get the sponge out, and be careful
with the bristles because you'll break down the fibers
too much.
This is an art form, okay?
So this, you want a soft brush.
Whip out that soft brush.
(Johnny chuckles)
All right, now, what do you think is the biggest change
you've made in yourself over the last decade?
Like the number one improvement.
My number one improvement,
I try to have thought before action.
Oh.
And I'm no longer coloring my hair.
You're a silver Fox.
How's yours?
Mine is literally, I wanna say proudly,
I believe it is perfect.
Mine probably could.
Mine could still use a little love, but,
my first time.
Oh yeah, interesting.
All right, well, this is where you literally, watch out.
Just dump the bleach on?
Dump the bleach on it.
Oh God, that's just gonna murder the shirt.
And then, and then you just stick it in the bath.
Put the baby right in the bath.
Put the baby in the bath?
Put the baby in the bath.
I love that improvement, PJ.
That's a really, really good, useful like, life skill.
Well, it's a pretty basic one that I,
I was ashamed I didn't even know people did.
It was mostly first thought, best thought.
One thing that I love about you is that you tell us all
to make life a big old apple
and take the juiciest delicious bite out of it.
Thank you for that.
(crowd cheers)
Thank you, Drew.
Whoa, I don't even know where the stain was.
All right, Johnny Knoxville, Jackass Forever.
Oh my God.
You need this.
We all need this.
I've seen it so many times now
and I'm gonna keep watching.
That's right, I'm gonna keep watching it.
It opens in theaters nationwide today!
Go get it!
(upbeat music)